bueno primero me gustaría presentarme
con todos ustedes mi nombre como ya lo
han dicho varias veces antes de llegar
aquí ella y ribera
y me dedicó principalmente a hacer
me dedicó principalmente a ser fotógrafo
filmmaker que es una manera muy chida de
decir que hago vídeos
y también soy catedrático en una
universidad ok el tema del que voy a
hablar también ya lo mencionaron quería
que fuera sorpresa es la paciencia
cuando entras a text una de las reglas
que te piden que debes de cumplir
es que lo que sea de lo que vayas a
hablar tienes que dominar lo tienes que
saber del tema del que vas a hablar no
puedes pararte aquí y hablar de un tema
que no conoces
soy yo freelance es decir me gusto
jugarle al emprendedor
he tenido que soportar muchísimos
muchísimos clientes a lo largo de mi
vida lo que me ha dado una especie de
coraza de protección de paciencia así es
como me gusta llamarla a la cual recurro
cada vez que tengo algún cliente
complicado no hay alguno de aquí que sea
este igual que yo emprendedor va a
entender a qué me refiero de lo
complicado que a veces sé lidiar con la
gente el segundo punto es que soy
maestro universitario de hecho gracias a
eso estoy aquí una alumna mía me nominó
y tengo que lidiar con jóvenes de 20
años que tienen la madurez emocional de
niños de primaria entonces entre que no
saben lo que quieren entre que me piden
permiso para entregar tarde las tareas
no sé si algunos de los que estén aquí
dan clases en una universidad y les ha
tocado vivir eso pero pasa mucho y entre
que tengo que lidiar con sus hormonas y
sus emociones también he aprendido a
desarrollar paciencia y finalmente y
creo que yo es el doctorado de la
paciencia estoy casado
no tengo que explicar más yo creo que
las personas que ya viven con alguien
entienden a lo que me refiero el tener a
una persona las 24 horas del día que te
está diciendo qué hacer cómo vestirte
cómo comer cómo moverte bueno
bajó hasta el tema
soy una persona aficionada del contenido
audiovisual así se llama ahora antes
decías de la tele de las películas pero
ya para generalizar del contenido
audiovisual me fascina me fascina todos
los temas de ciencia ficción el símbolo
que ustedes ven ahí es esa silueta de un
vehículo de una película muy famosa que
se llama volver al futuro es algo que a
mí me apasiona mucho todo este tipo de
temas vamos a viajar al pasado debería
llamarse volver al pasado verdad la
película viajando al pasado pero bueno
volvamos al pasado un poquito vamos a
hablar de cómo se consumían los
productos audiovisuales en el pasado en
el pasado para las personas que nacieron
en mi época que es como para ir el 85
vamos a entender mucho de lo que les voy
a comentar para que una película
apareciera en televisión abierta no digo
cable porque yo no era rico no tenía
cable
tenía yo que ver televisión abierta
tardaba 5 años aproximadamente en
colocarse una película yo para los que
nacieron aquí después de los 90s no
estoy bromeando es real 5 años en que
llegará una película a la televisión 24
horas era el tiempo que tomaba a un
noticiero recopilar información y
publicarla
al otro día dígase un periódico y
algunas veces en televisión pasaba lo
mismo pasaba algún día antes y al otro
día se estaba enterando de lo que estaba
pasando y también tardaban 30 días las
famosas revistas yo consumí muchas
revistas porque soy medio friki me gusta
mucho todo lo que son los temas de
caricaturas temas niños y todo ese tipo
de temas para que yo pudiera estar
enterado de mis animes favoritos
tardábamos 30 días en que llegara una
revista yo gran fan de una revista de
videojuegos 30 días
de esos 30 días de esas 24 horas de esos
cinco años créanme que la mayoría de
nosotros sabíamos y comprendimos al cien
por ciento lo que era el esperar algo y
esto es lo que me lleva a mi siguiente
punto
el proceso
es el proceso el proceso es un conjunto
de fases sucesivas y necesarias para
llegar a un objetivo en común oa un
destino en particular el proceso es algo
que se tiene que cumplir para que
podamos obtener algo la misma vida es un
proceso
naces creces engordas te reproduces
sigues engordando y mueres eso es parte
del proceso de la vida ese proceso
a nosotros nos permite entender que todo
aquello que queremos lleva un tiempo una
manera de hacerse todo tiene tiempo todo
ahí para todo hay un tiempo y una forma
de hacer las cosas
quiero comentarles lo siguiente vamos a
volver otra vez ok al futuro regresemos
ahora si volvemos al futuro regresemos a
estos tiempos como consumimos
actualmente la información
la información es inmediata hace algún
tiempo de hecho incluso el mismo
compañero que pasó hace un momento todas
esas noticias que suceden en la ciudad
en el país nos enteramos nosotros al
momento siempre yo siempre dicho cómo es
que le hace pero la prensa llega primero
que todo si ya está haciendo un en vivo
transmitiendo todo lo que está pasando
la información es inmediata el mundo se
ha vuelto mucho más pequeño pero esto es
debido a que ya estamos mucho más
conectados el internet nos ha vuelto una
civilización mucho más conectada el
internet nos ha ayudado porque es real
nos ha ayudado a conectarnos entre
nosotros
en el ámbito comunicacional si lo
queremos ver así
por ejemplo lo que les platicaba yo de
que antes tardaban cinco años en
aparecer en televisión una película hoy
en día no sucede
netflix por ejemplo de hecho del tema
netflix en el momento que estrena una
película en cine también la está
estrenando su plataforma y muchas veces
cualquier sistema de streaming si tú ves
una película de cine termina de estar en
cartelera y ya está disponible para que
las puedas ver en tu casa antes íbamos
al cine porque no había otra opción para
ver una película ahora vamos al cine
porque queremos verlo en pantalla grande
de hecho de ese cuenta que es la forma
en la que te venden actualmente el que
tengas que ir al cine tienes que ir
porque es pantalla grande y todo esto ha
sido precisamente por esta situación
ahora quiero aclarar algo no estoy
diciendo nada en contra del internet de
internet es una gran herramienta me
entienden esto ha sido algo maravilloso
me encanta vivir en esta época en donde
cualquier persona tiene la capacidad de
transmitir sus pensamientos o ideas
usando plataformas como por ejemplo tex
tex es una plataforma que sirve para
compartir
y eso es lo que estamos haciendo
actualmente y lo que todos los que
estamos aquí compartiremos una idea en
un momento
pero esto no quiere decir que el
compartir una idea sea algo positivo
siempre aquí viene donde yo les explico
por qué el tema de netflix el efecto
netflix para mí es aquel a través del
cual nosotros abusamos de esta
inmediatez de la información en internet
cualquier cosa en la vida si se consume
con exceso es malo todo es malo en
exceso nada es bueno en exceso el exceso
es un problema y el problema actualmente
es que la gente consume a una velocidad
tan grande que cuando sale una serie
completa en netflix
yo tengo alumnos al otro día con ojeras
que me vienen platicando de que trato la
serie y saben qué es lo que me dicen al
final ya estoy esperando la segunda
temporada
ya no existe esa misma paciencia que
muchos de nosotros nos tocó vivir cuando
éramos más jóvenes que teníamos que
esperar un tiempo teníamos que esperar
un proceso para que llegara a nosotros
la información ahora es el momento y
esto me lleva a otro punto le digo que
me gusta mucho el tema de contenido
audiovisual en las películas existe
existe un concepto que se llama la
elipsis
si saben quién es el personaje que sale
y de hecho abajo está su nombre por si
no lo sabe
él es rock y balboa cuando a mí me
explicó hace mucho tiempo un maestro
sobre la elipsis en el cine me puso como
ejemplo a rocky balboa todos han
escuchado alguna vez voy a tararear lo y
no lo voy a cantar lo voy a tararear
esta canción tan tan tan tan tan tan tan
tan tan tan tan tan tan tan tan tan
ese momento en el cual se ve a rocky
preparándose físicamente para
enfrentarse a apollo creed ese momento
se llama elipsis se resumieron 4 o 5
meses de la vida de rocky balboa en una
canción de menos de un minuto
y les voy a decir una cosa actualmente
muchos jóvenes piensan que la vida es
así de fácil que no tiene que haber un
proceso porque tengo que esperar para
poder lograr algo porque tengo que
hacerlo si acabo de ver una película que
sólo pongo una canción tan tanto
tratando y ya no soy doctor no o pongo
la canción tan tanta tanta conquista la
chava no o pongo la canción tan tan tan
tan para un bebé
no es fácil la vida nos ha comprobado
que no existen elipsis las elipsis solo
existen en la cinematografía nada más lo
demás todo lo demás lleva a un proceso
es precisamente por eso que estoy aquí
en esta ocasión quiero que entendamos lo
necesario que es para nuestra vida el
tener paciencia si ustedes no aprenden a
tener paciencia van a sufrir y no van a
obtener nada con ese sufrimiento la
paciencia es una actitud que a nosotros
nos va a permitir enfrentar cualquier
situación cualquier cosa que estemos
atravesando y resistir la para obtener
un resultado al final eso es la
paciencia es una actitud la paciencia de
hecho literalmente viene del verbo pat
del latin path que significa sufrir
sufrir paciencia igual a sufrir ahora no
estoy diciendo con esto que toda la vida
van a tener que sufrir para obtener algo
a veces la vida te da regalos te da
cosas que obtienes de forma rápida y sin
sufrimiento son regalos aprovecha los
abraza los toma los son tuyos pero la
mayor parte de las cosas de la vida las
vas a obtener en base
una especie de sufrimiento es decir a un
proceso a una espera no va a ser fácil
no va a ser fácil ahora quién es el
culpable de toda esta impaciencia
nosotros las generaciones que conocimos
la paciencia y que ahora también estamos
impacientando nos ha que salga la
segunda temporada para poder ver no las
en una noche en netflix nosotros somos
responsables de eso es nuestra
responsabilidad enseñarles a los más
pequeños a los que no conocieron el
mundo en el que nos criamos lo que es la
paciencia lo que es esperar es nuestra
responsabilidad
siempre que hablo de este tema la mayor
parte de la gente no está dispuesta a
pagar el precio mis alumnos cada vez que
les comento esto me dicen es que ya no
tienes por qué sufrir si tú haces esto
de una forma o de otra no hijo siempre
vas a tener que atravesar un proceso
todo lo que vale la pena tener se cuesta
creo que la mayoría de los que estamos
aquí entendemos esto todo tiene un
precio y no me refiero a que todos son
vendibles sino me refiero a que todo
tiene un proceso para poder obtenerse
de verdad estoy muy contento y
agradecido de estar aquí incluso el
hecho de que yo estoy aquí en este
momento es parte de un proceso no
sucedió antes tampoco ha sucedido
después soy parte de ese proceso también
soy parte de esa paciencia que me ayudó
a estar aquí en este momento
así que
seamos pacientes por favor con todo lo
que hagamos con cualquier emprendimiento
con cualquier idea que tengamos para que
podamos obtener esos resultados que
queremos muchas gracias por su paciencia
[Aplausos]